whenever a movie has a really cool
premise but totally fails to deliver it
leaves us asking questions like what
happened and should they remake it and
can I get a refund whether it's a
totally original idea that doesn't pay
off like people using time as literal
currency or a killer book that was
bungled when the movie was made
um Percy Jackson or even a meta
commentary on action movies cue the
Arnold Schwarzenegger Montage it's such
a bummer when movies that should have
been great aren't I distinctly remember
when I saw the trailer for jumper and
said out loud oh man absolutely and why
not TBH it looked dope it was the
ultimate wish fulfillment movie about a
guy played by Hayden Christensen who
could teleport himself anywhere in the
world whenever he wanted and of course
he uses his powers to have all sorts of
fun robbing banks chilling at the top of
the Sphinx's head in Egypt yada yada
until he starts getting hunted by a
group that knows about his powers I mean
the bad guy was Samuel L Jackson what
I'd like to know is how you rob a bank
without opening any doors which
automatically takes any movie up a few
notches I mean Jackson vs Anakin
Skywalker with teleportation how could
this movie not rock and yet somehow it
didn't and now a quick pop over to
Rotten Tomatoes and yeah not great it's
got a 15 from critics and a 44 for
audience scores which is to be fair a
little generous the movie just didn't
work it seemed like they were maybe
trying to set it up as a franchise and
didn't put enough effort into making the
first one slap oh well the star power of
Hayden Christensen and Sam Jackson
couldn't save jumper and the star power
of Justin Timberlake and Amanda Seyfried
weren't enough to do anything for the
flop in time it had a really killer
premise it's the year 2169 and everyone
stops aging at age 25 but here's the
catch each person has a timer on their
arm showing how much remaining time they
have left in their life and when it hits
zero the person dies however you can
prolong your life by literally buying
more time and of course like a precursor
to the districts and The Hunger Games
Society is divided up by time zones
where the rich have all the time they'd
ever want and the poor are continuously
on their final 24 hours trying to buy
more time as an allegory for wealth
disparity it works as an entertaining
movie not so much not even JT can bring
the sexy back to this stud I think film
critic Richard Probst may have put it
best when he wrote there's nothing more
precious than time and for that reason
alone I'll encourage you to not waste
yours and avoid in time speaking of time
isn't it time you hit that subscribe
button we don't offer more years on your
life but we do have a lot of great and
entertaining vids so that's pretty cool
reading Rick Riordan's book Saga Percy
Jackson and the Olympians is not a waste
of time it's a classic sadly the two
movie versions of that story are very
much not when the 2010 movie Percy
Jackson and the Olympians the Lightning
Thief came out fans of the books were
over the moon they assumed the movie
would be the start of a series that
would parallel the books a la the Harry
Potter flicks and then they saw the
movie and well it didn't go great it's
hard to blame the studio for trying to
make the movie happen when the IP you're
working off is a beloved story your
movie premise is already spun in gold
for you of course that can turn out to
be a curse too when they adapted the
story of young Percy who discovers early
on that he's the son of the Greek god
Poseidon they made some major changes
for starters they bailed on one of the
basics of the premise which was that
Percy goes from being a young boy to a
teen but to make it appeal to a wider
audience the studio shifted him to a 16
year old at the beginning and for anyone
who has been either of those ages you
know they are not the same they also
changed a bunch of other things to the
point where after the second movie was
released they pulled the plug on making
the movies all together ish the good
news is there's a TV series coming out
soon and it was created in conjunction
with Reardon so odds are good it'll Rock
Let's talk about Will Smith
I was thinking about it you know well
there's many amazing movies as Will
Smith has been in people often forget
about Hancock and to be fair that's
probably because it wasn't very good and
yet most people agree that it had the
potential to be an Alzheimer the premise
being basically Hancock is a superhuman
who can fly is impervious to being hurt
and is super strong oh and he's a major
jerk and before you go all wait isn't
that what the show the boys is about yes
it's a similar idea but Hancock came way
first and the word on the street is that
the OG screenplay for it was dope but as
tends to happen it sat in production
Purgatory for more than a decade and
when it finally got made the script had
been Rewritten and watered down so it
would appeal to a wider audience and In
fairness that kind of worked it ended up
being the fourth highest grossing movie
of 2008 but everyone who saw it had that
same feeling this was decent but it
could have been so much better it's
especially true when you think about its
killer cast besides Will Smith it had
Charlize the Ron and Jason Bateman
that's a pretty fun Trio in my opinion
when Last Action Hero was released
Arnold Schwarzenegger was arguably a
bigger star than Will Smith was with
Hancock he was the action hero so when
this comedy action flick appeared in
theaters everybody assumed it would be a
classic Arnold movie especially because
it was ahead of the curve when it comes
to being meta Arnold basically played a
version of himself and the premise was a
kid gets magically transported into the
world of an action movie fun right
haven't you watched an action flick and
wondered what it would be like to be in
the movie it was a wink to the
over-the-top nature of Arnold's action
movies and it was pretty cool that he
was able to kind of make fun of himself
and the genre to be honest maybe this
movie was a little too far ahead of the
curve and they didn't quite know how to
pull it off regardless it was a huge box
office flop and while the critics didn't
hate it hate it the general consensus
was it had a ton of potential that it
didn't live up to if you have problems
with the with the shooting it doesn't
mean it's a bad movie I think if you
just go to bed wrap while Sucker Punch
didn't live up to its potential it at
least kind of lived up to its name
because most people felt like they'd
been sucker punched when they watched it
it had a really promising premise a
young woman tries to get out of a mental
institution and only has a few days to
do it before she's forced to have a
lobotomy she gets four other women in
the institution to help her and they
attempt to kick butt and take names on
their magical and surreal Journey out
unfortunately the end result was a
hodgepodge of sexist tropes and subpar
fight scenes even the lead character
named baby doll of all things uses her
body to seduce the bad guys and the
women in the film are all in these tight
skimpy outfits that look like they could
have been rejected from certain scenes
of Fifty Shades of Gray what seemed most
disappointing was that not only did
Sucker Punch have a really fun and cool
premise but it also missed out on a
chance to be a movie that let women kick
butt in an empowering and cool way
instead it played more like the fantasy
film of a fresh frustrated teen boy that
one had to like the architecture and
everything had to sort of the Two Worlds
had to speak to each other when it came
to the movie downsizing this was another
one that when I saw the trailer I got
hyped seriously after you watch this
video go watch the trailer for
downsizing even though you already know
the movie is disappointing a party you
will be like but maybe it is good well
sadly it's not most people who watched
it felt like it was a bait and switch
the trailer and commercials made it to
be somewhat of a wacky but heartfelt
comedy like a grown-up version of Honey
I Shrunk the Kids but not to give too
much away but it kind of quickly veers
away from that it ends up as a bizarre
bummer of a story that aims to teach us
all life lessons but mostly makes us
yearn to watch the trailer again and get
back to our happy place even a fantastic
cast including the likes of Matt Damon
Kristen wig and Christoph Waltz couldn't
save downsizing I couldn't believe that
anyone was gonna pay for it because it's
a big movie it's an expensive movies
with a Rotten Tomatoes audience score of
24 percent it seems like I wasn't the
only one thrown off by the promise of a
really cool premise only to be
blindsided by a disappointing final
product okay I'm gonna go re-watch
Ocean's 11 because that one has a great
premise and always goes down smooth do
you have thoughts on other movies that
had great premises but failed to deliver
pop them in the comments section